als ob junge der das so frei sich auf
mich gehabt hätte hör auf mit diesem
system ist er nicht wieder ihr seht mich
auf ich muss die ganze zeit verstanden
lasst mich in ruhe ich nicht jola die
hessen kommen zu dieser folge von alten
sieg mittlerweile heute der akkudeckel
hey hallo sven simon vorn
wir spielen jetzt hatten sich zehn bis
zwanzig und die leute verstecken sich 32
21 12 geschlagen wirst du heute stress
bei dem objekt um 15.30 komme hallo wir
werden nicht mit schnee weil er keinen
start kann sein ok nach sind steiner
drin
möbel alte kläger irgendeiner spielt ja
irgend einer esoterischen spieler mit
basketball ok hat das war dieses junge
der erste der sich zeigt er bekommt also
ich zeit mich nein arbeiten bisher in
die natur genießen kommt welcher hund
legalisiert ich wo bist du
ich bin ganz weit weg von der spitze der
contact gestoppt oder und mit dem pinsel
der farbpinsel dkb ging muss der hund
bist du wollen warum man da hab dich so
so wer ist der nächste
wir fliegen hauptsache ist hier noch wie
alle rumlaufen weiner thema einfach
unsichtbarkeit aktiviert leon sorry ich
will eigentlich gerne jetzt geht man
schon bisher auslöschen
ich finde ich mache jetzt musst du ja wo
ist denn der sagt dir sagt mal wo ist
denn der von dir ausgesehen denn
irgendwie zu mich nicht jonathan sich
hier sind hier ein junger gott wer bist
du
hallo ich zeige ja so
du bist so ein er stellt sich dagegen
und hören musik der pr ich glaube ich
weiß was du jetzt schon so tritt im
widerstand wo ist jemand auf dem dach um
laufen
er zeige ich habe das gefühl meine
spitze sind nicht so ganz so produktiv
wie ich mir das erhofft habe alle macht
ja nichts daran gesehen hab dich wer
bist du denn es kann nur eins kann ein
luchs geben wie viele fehler es fehlt
noch geht mal so viel
wo ist irgendetwas mit mir suchen und
nicht mehr mit tipps geben
bist du ich habe der king ist in
irgendwelche verwandlungen verstrickt
und dafür jetzt nichts sagen also ich
glaub ich glaube wirklich gefällt ihm
gerade ein messer an die brust
ich glaube der ist bei diesen eltern
oder habe ich weglaufen nein
und irgendwann darf nicht weglaufen ok
ok haben wir leon schon nein aber jetzt
gleichauf hallo herr lässt sich nicht
mal können die wunderkerzen gefunden
also werde ich sagen ich bin schon
gefallen oder mit dass das eigentlich
schon da einer ist gerade höflich an mir
also die skins müssen sich gestreift
haben einer ist sogar mir vorbeigelaufen
garten also leute die so viel ist ein
gartenzwerg scanner ist irgendwo wo sie
dienstag komplett
genau da bin ich ja schon vorbei ja das
glaube ich habe nicht gesehen okay jetzt
schon tot
ich stehe immer noch um die alte
ich glaube das war ein gutes hofer hier
mehr regale
hier geht es glaube ich noch irgendein
junge der schalk der dumme
so aber ich freue mich so dass ich jetzt
nicht mehr suchen muss ich habe absolut
keinen bock mehr für super oder was ja
dann verstecken uns jetzt in griffen
nicht in gebäude rein nicht im gebäude
nicht im gebäude
alle versteckten wartet ja ich glaube
ich habe das beste stück
dabei darf man nein ich bin runter
gefallen darf man sich in diesen
komischen büschen verstecken also wenn
diesen großen bambus freesien meisterin
mit ja das ist gut zu wissen weil der
winter nicht mehr welchen scan hast du
fußballer
er hatte keinen ronaldo naja jetzt
nehmen wir nur mal versteckt sie sagen
denkst du so typisch decken versteckt
dabei die erste mal zu überlegen wo ich
den locker wissen wieder irgendwo vom
baum nein ist noch nicht auf ansage ich
glaube ich für mich irgendwo oben
als ob junge der das sofa sich auf mich
gehabt
wir sprechen ja heute laufen aber du
weißt ja dass nicht die wollen sie auch
so ohne gebäude okay sollte es dem
gegenüber steht ein weißes kein dummes
kommst du näher als dave dee bis
irgendwo irgendwann war entweder im park
offenbar schon mal eine gute idee
ok dahinter die wir direkt einer gerade
erst durch erhält er nur mit dem
fallschirm machen kannst ja fast von 31
schon auf dem boden opfer und das immer
wieder was für einer bist nächsten
ausfahrt hast du bist doch der auf dem
dachgarten bei diesen tricks da hat ja
heute treppe
er ist bin ich genau ich sehe dich aber
du kannst mich sehen dass das nicht mehr
passiert ich kann nicht sehen dass ich
sagen zuerst mit dem vollidioten weg
dann gucke ich sehe euch beide war ihr
seht mich auch was ich mir die ganze
zeit verstanden wird mich in ruhe ich
nicht also halt nicht in gebäuden
naja ihnen gebäuden nicht im gebäude
aber vielleicht auf gebäuden oder an
[Musik]
gebäuden
thomas hat sich verraten womit niemand
einige denken kannst was aber hat gesagt
er weiter er meinte der mischung aus im
park und auf dem bau genutzt das ist
krass oh mein gott ich nein du hast mich
hat sich durch die wast zu klosters so
stellen sie ein bisschen
[Gelächter]
hallo was das alter dieser strecke weil
man das besser versteckt der welt war so
geil einer so schlechten heutige dass
mit diesem video vielen dank dass ihr
alle seid schaut auf jeden fall bei leon
bei sven ich hoffe so viel vorbei und
das was mit diesem video
wir sehen von nächsten anders funktionen
[Musik]